i'm here at stanford medical school with
neil gazunt who's a faculty member
faculty member here at the med school
hi so
what are we going to talk about
well the topic for today is
endocrinology which is the study of
hormones
and
the word hormone is derived from the
greek word which means arouse the
activity and what hormones do is they're
chemical messengers that are made at one
part of the body and typically go to
another part of the body too as
suggested arouse the activity and give
function to
another organ so they're essentially
kind of signaling way to communicate
between one part of the body and the
other exactly they're very sophisticated
communicators i think that's a perfect
term and i think the other way to think
of it is our body communicates in some
ways directly for instance nerves
innervate muscle right and when you want
to contract your muscle you give a
signal from your brain it goes down the
nerve and it directly attaches to the
muscle and causes it to contract
whereas hormones are more like the wi-fi
of the human body they're wireless
they are made at one place they go into
the bloodstream which is like the
airwaves if you will and then they um
they
work on another part of the body at a
distance without
without directly connecting um to that
part of the body um
mechanically and are hormones are they a
specific type of protein or specific
type of chemical are there really
anything that does what you just
described it's pretty much anything but
they fall into two major categories
they're small molecules that typically
derive from amino acids and those
molecules are just oh 300 to 500 at most
daltons which are molecular mass units
okay up to large proteins that can be
hundreds and hundreds of amino acids in
size i see so anything anything that
just really has a signaling function
that's right would be considered a
hormone right and the other thing is we
talk about hormones in three sort of
subcategories we call some of them
endocrine hormones where they really get
into the bloodstream and work at a far
distance and we'll give some examples
with your diagram right there in just a
minute but there are others that are
called paracrine hormones
and paracrine hormones are more
regionally active so they might be made
let's say in one part of the body and
work within a small distance of that
site of synthesis
and then the third category which is
less common would be autocrine hormones
and the autocrine hormones are actually
made directly at one cell and work on
that same cell or in the cell right next
door at a very very small distance i see
are these things you know when you work
so the endocrine hormones like i think i
have a mental model for it they're kind
of released and
far away in the body someplace if
they're picked up by the right receptor
they'll they'll have the right function
the parakin hormones is their effect
small because they only are able to
travel a small distance or is it
something else
typically the paracrine hormones
do get into the bloodstream but the
concentration of the receptor the
receiving end as you suggested is right
close by so it tends to make a paracrine
hormone work regionally is that the high
concentration of the receptors are very
close to the cytosynthesis i see i see
and the same with autocrine is often
they're made and there's a very high
concentration of the receiving end right
at that cell
right next to that cell and this might
be a silly question but you know it's
called endocrinology are there are there
parachronologists
uh well i i it's a good point i don't
think so i think we just perhaps because
the paracord function of hormones was
discovered later
we still carry this all under the
umbrella of endocrinology right so the
all of hormones is endocrinology even
though endocrine hormones are the ones
that act at far distances that's right i
think that's a good way to summarize it
now i like the diagram that you created
here because it illustrates some of the
major endocrine organs the ones we'll be
focusing on in later lectures so the
first one that you showed very nicely in
the head at the base of the brain is
that orange structure and that would be
the pituitary gland that's right and the
pituitary gland is called the master
gland because from the pituitary we make
hormones that work on yet other organs
right so i'll give you an example one of
the hormones that's made by the
pituitary is called thyroid stimulating
hormone or tsh
and after it leaves the pituitary it
goes into the circulation
and it acts on the thyroid gland where
there are high receptors for tsh on the
surface of the thyroid cells
and it stimulates the thyroid gland to
make thyroid hormone typically thyroxine
t4
or
triiodothyronine t3 those would be the
two main circulating thyroid hormones
and what do those do those regulate
metabolism they regulate appetite they
regulate thermogenesis they regulate
muscle function they have widespread
activities on other parts of the body
but it kind of upregulates or
downregulates the entire body in the
metabolism that's right so someone with
hyperthyroidism would have very high
metabolism you may know the the classic
picture of someone with a high heart
rate rapid metabolism weight loss that
would be some with excess amounts of
thyroid hormone and then you see pretty
much the inverse picture when someone
has a deficiency of thyroid hormone and
some with hypothyroidism so it's
critical to maintain just the right
amount of almost all of these hormones
and the thyroid hormones are good
examples of that but the ultimate
regulation is from that pituitary right
this is kind of the master one it sends
a signal there and then that kind of
that's right
and we'll talk later about feedback
loops because how does the pituitary
know when to stop making tsh and
basically like a thermostat it can sense
the levels of thyroid hormone and when
those levels are just at the right level
and not too high it'll decrease the
amount of tsh it makes if the levels are
too low it'll increase tsh to try to
stimulate the thyroid gland to make yet
more thyroid hormone very cool
and what else do we have okay so the
other hormones some of the major ones
the pituitary in addition to making the
thyroid stimulating hormones it makes a
hormone called acth
adrenocorticotrophic hormone which acts
on the adrenal cortex and the adrenal is
that gland exactly that sits on top of
the kidney
and the outer layers of the adrenal
gland are the adrenal cortex and those
are stimulated uh by acth
and they don't they're not related to
the kidney they just sit on top there
they're naturally there right they're
they're related only in the sense that
they the blood supply is rich like the
kidneys blood supply and they happen to
sit above the kidney um and they're
called adrenal because they're adjacent
to the kidney renal part that should
have been obvious but but they don't per
se uh you know uh filter blood or do any
of the key functions that the kidney
subserves i see and what what are the
what's their role so the adrenal glands
make um the adrenal hormones like
cortisol which regulates glucose
metabolism and is important to
maintaining blood pressure and
well-being and then it makes
mineralocorticoids like aldosterone
which is important for regulating salt
and water balance
you also have adrenal androgens which
are somewhat important and those three
hormones are the main hormones made by
the adrenal cortex i see
the acth primarily regulates the
cortisol and the adrenal androgens and
there's another system that regulates
the mineralocorticoids that we'll talk
about later okay and we have a few more
organs here yeah so also out of the
pituitary we make luteinizing hormone
and follicle stimulating hormone those
will be abbreviated lh and fsh lh and
fsh and those act on the gonads so in
the male it'll act on the testis and the
female it'll act on the ovaries
to stimulate the development of sperm in
the male and uh oocytes or eggs in the
female and also the production of
gonadal steroids primarily testosterone
in the male and estradiol and the female
right right and are
we missing anything well there are two
other hormones that also derived from
the anterior pituitary and those would
be growth hormone that's critical for
optimal growth of long bones uh the
territory really does do a lot it does
yeah
and so that would so it's hard to drive
human growth hormone yeah human growth
hormone and that would act on long bones
for instance and then we would have
prolactin which is important uh in women
for um lactation being able to
breastfeed after delivering it and
insulin is
insulin is key but it doesn't come from
the pituitary so now we're going to work
our way down a little bit we talked
about the thyroid gland making thyroid
hormone and then when you get to the
pancreas which is that yellow structure
right in the middle
inside the pancreas there are
small islands called the eyelids of
longer hans
and the islets within the uh pancreas
make endocrine hormones
like insulin and glucagon but insulin is
vital without insulin you have diabetes
right and without insulin you don't uh
transport glucose into muscle and remove
glucose from the bloodstream normally
right and that the absence of insulin
can produce all of the symptoms of
diabetes that we'll talk about later
right and it seems just structurally you
have the pancreas right here you have
the adrenal glands right there that
they're all near those kind of that
interchange on the the because they're
also important to to
get to where they need to get that's a
good observation they all have a lot of
venous drainage from them so that when
they make their hormone it gets into the
bloodstream rather quickly because they
are vital structures very cool so i
think i think we could leave it there
and then in the next video you have some
pictures i think would be pretty
interesting okay yeah in the next video
we'll talk about sort of how you have to
have the right amount of the hormone or
else things go awry very cool thanks a
bunch okay thank you